that fellow right there taco fall boy
significant input is necessary for him
type on the floor I think you got to use
it when he's in there's a cross screen
of wine is the shortest fall after a
dunk of white paper nice little catch
and drop step and you're right it's a
real short fall after that play but you
see the improvement the hands the
mobility nice little catch and drop step
and you're right head down here for
Dawkins gets the basket and a foul if
you look at the size of him running him
down right there press it blank letters
fall same note it's his second block of
the game and it's
Ram there you go
I don't know what you're gonna do but
there you go and try to shoot it the
status block block number three by Todd
that's a second great cut make himself
available blocked again by fall his
court defensive Jim's here to open up
the second half that block right there
his second one right here of the second
defensive Jim's here to open up the
second half that block right there he's
speed with the dribble was unbelievable
look at this that's the it makes it
easier right there sit down and he's got
a double-double tonight
hanging almost get back right at it he's
okay they are the harder they fall nice
footwork
nice touch inside oh good he didn't
really bang the head at the end he may
got hit in the forehead there that's
[Applause]
that's a bang the head at the end they
may got hit the far head there that's as
far as Jenkins you cannot jump on once
without the second type of post area you
they out jump up but blocks but your
first March Madness experience what was
that like for you out there it was
awesome after four years of hard work
you know just into a coat the coaches
just teaching us a lot and trusting the
process we found them married but we
care me we're not satisfied the guys
willing to work they're not satisfied
I'm sure enough next is Diane Williamson
and Duke a tremendous matchup for you
and I know you had a chance to watch him
a little bit while you're out here
before your game your thoughts their
great great great bunch of kids man
they're very talented Coach K I mean
coasted tomorrow by him because he
played for him but great bringing great
team and I'm looking forward to
you're Smith Paulo de taco de Lara a
behind him puts it up and off the back
of the river is chained down by taco
fall he died of taco fall early UCF
loves to go inside to the big guy but
look at this that's just not fair you
know a steady diet of taco is knocked
died of taco fall early UCF loves to go
inside to the big guy but look at this
that's just not fair net foul actually
he's called on Dawkins dumping it down
low Zion on the blocks challenge
taco fall one zip who said not this time
right here this look like a hard shell
taco with this Taylor
[Applause]
second dunk already is the length of the
speed up to able to cover so much
distance and I like this right here you
got a talent atacó for two and the
Knights have come out with the first
five points of the second half looking
for more long with a slim Johnny told us
he's learned how to play understanding
him and I get to the rim and finish with
the plateau Tom late in the shot clock
they've been going a little bit of man
his flash to the bank Williamson and
ball risky move but got a hand on it and
seven to six contests to that range
shots they don't get back Paco de LOI no
foul call but another dunk Taylor the
senior with three to shoot they call Big
Shot Perry off the floor top get squat
[Applause]